one of the defining characteristics of
the EU is its politics by consensus
model of operation obviously not all 28
member states and their representatives
in Parliament are going to agree all the
time
and so compromise and consensus of the
order of the day at the very heart of
that is the president of the European
Council the man or woman charged with
bringing together the leaders and
ministers of the Member States to
advance the EU agenda in all its huge
variety who is the president of the
European Council what is their role
inside and outside view what are their
powers and responsibilities the thing to
establish from the get-go is he is not
the president of the European Union as
it's sometimes believed there isn't one
of those the three main institutions the
Commission Council and the column and
each have their own president the
president of the European Council brings
together the --use 28 heads of state and
government who meet at summits at least
four times a year sometimes more these
last few years with the economic and
refugee crises it was more like seven
times a year what was the President
appointed according to the Lisbon Treaty
it's the heads of state and government
who nominate the president many don't
actually approve of the appointment but
there's a lot of horse-trading strictly
behind closed doors at European summits
without a real campaign or election
fight once appointed the president then
has a mandate of two and a half years
renewable once it's a rather well-paid
job the president receives a monthly
salary of around 25,000 euros
give or take the same as the president
of the European Commission the second
president the former polish Prime
Minister Donald Tusk was appointed in
December 2014 succeeding the first the
former Belgian Prime Minister Hammond
fan Rompuy the idea of having a
president at all was to avoid
continuously changing European council
presidency before 2010 each head of
state or government headed the council
for six months this rotation was
dizzying and impeded proper monitoring
and execution of all the dossiers and I
were the fixed president the preparation
of European summits has become more
efficient if
if the rotating six-month country
presidencies haven't disappeared
concretely what does the president do
essentially he's three F's fixer of
meetings finder of compromise and
facilitator of consensus after each
summit the European Council president
goes to the European Parliament to
present the conclusions that have been
adopted is then grilled by any piece
abroad the president represents the
European Union a big set piece events
like the g7 and g20 along with the
president of the Commission as to
whether Europe should develop a
dedicated president of Europe roll
president who represents both the
European Commission and the Member
States well an idea does surface
regularly but it's not going to happen
anytime soon